I want to be clear about the ccla's
position
the protests needed to be addressed but
the government also had an obligation to
comply with the law and use emergency
Powers as a truly Last Resort
that was not the case and it is our
opinion that their actions were unlawful
and unconstitutional
we are going into the commission with an
open mind but in our view the government
has yet to prove that the legal
threshold to invoke the Act was met
and the burden is on them not the other
way around
this is what we will be focusing on at
the commission the federal government's
decision to invoke the Act and the
constitutionality of the emergency
orders that it put in place
as a participant in the inquiry with
full standing we will vigorously test
the government's evidence and demand
that the government is held to account
for its actions
we believe that the inquiry must address
several important questions
including first and foremost was the
legal threshold for invoking the ACT met
where their genuine concerns about
threats to National Security or was the
government largely concerned about the
economic impacts of the blockades
what evidence supported the government's
view that there was a threat to security
or a serious threat to a lives health or
safety of Canadians
why according to the government were
existing laws inadequate to address the
emergency
what alternatives did the government
consider could legislation passed on an
expedited basis have avoided the
invocation of the ACT
why were the emergency orders drafted so
broadly
when the protests were localized why was
application to the entire country
considered necessary
how did the protests and blockades
impact the rights and freedoms of people
in Canada
and perhaps more significantly how did
the emergency orders that were put in
place impact the rights and freedoms of
people in Canada
when the emergencies Act was first
proposed as a bill the Canadian civil
liberties Association advocated for
Meaningful oversight and accountability
mechanisms to ensure that the gross
violations of civil liberties that had
taken place under the war measures act
would not be repeated
the commission of inquiry is an
important accountability mechanism and
the ccla is looking forward to helping
to ensure that it is a meaningful one
the inquiry will also provide the
broader Canadian public with the
opportunity to gain a greater
understanding
of the events that took place and come
to their own conclusions about some of
the issues at play
my colleague Ellen will give our
statement in French and then we'll be
happy to take your questions
in January and February
to be demonstrated
foreign foreign
foreign
I look forward to your question thank
you merci and that will go to the
questions first in the room and then on
Zuma
um
we have Stuart Benson from the hill
times
hi there
um you said that it you didn't believe
that the emergencies Act was used as a
measure of Last Resort uh and or that it
could have been dealt with sort of uh
expedited legislation are there any
specific examples that you can think of
that the government could have used
instead because I think some of the
problem was
even if there were existing laws the
police seemed unable or didn't have the
resources to enforce those laws so just
are there any examples you have of what
they could have done well I think I
think it's an interesting question about
the resources because I think
um you know as as I'm as I'm reading
through the the documents that have been
produced and um and looking at at some
of the evidence that I think will come
out over the course of the commission
um it it seems like the the resources
that were requested by the Ottawa Police
Service in particular
um sort of finally came through right
around the same time as um as the Act
was invoked so I think there's a
question there about whether
um you know which which had more impact
um but but if you think about you know
um situations where the government is in
a very um difficult situation like um
like a labor strike for example of of
um you know essential workers
um there have been instances where the
government has gone to Parliament and
passed legislation very quickly to get
those people back to work now that's not
something we would want to see happen on
a regular basis
um but but I think there is a question
here about why
um if if we did need new laws um why
couldn't we pass those laws rather than
use an emergency measure which places
all of the control in the hands of the
executive and and takes it out of the
control of parliament that's one of the
questions I think we think needs to be
answered
follow-up yeah
um and just with the legislation uh part
uh do you think that that would have
been possible considering this sort of
uh
I guess the atmosphere in the House of
Commons at the time when you had uh some
conservative uh MPS that were at the
very least uh not uh against or opposed
to the protesters do you think they
would have been able to have gotten that
through
I guess I I would expect that you know
um sort of emergency legislation as it
were would probably Garner the same
level of support that the the
proclamation did so I think it probably
could have passed there was you know I
think there was support for that but
I'll ask my questions in English if you
don't mind I was wondering we had some
of the answers to your questions during
the Parliamentary committee so why are
these uh answers unsatisfying for
instance the invoke the
blockades in other areas of the country
in Kutz Alberta Emerson Manitoba to say
that it had to apply to the whole
country so why is it not sufficient in
your eyes so I mean the the the blockade
in in Coots was
um dismantled before the emergency
um was invoked
um and it's not to say that uh you know
when we say that it didn't have to apply
to the whole country that doesn't
necessarily mean it it could only apply
to one place it could apply to more than
one
um but you know it applied to uh to the
territories where as far as we know
there was nothing happening
um you know uh it applied to the
maritimes that had a couple of
um I think of of early you know convoys
but but nothing on the level that we saw
in in Ottawa
um and you know I think one of the uh
really significant things that we're
concerned about was
um the the breadth of those emergency
orders and how that breadth was
communicated to the public because I
think there was
um
I think the government may have
um
used the confusion that the breadth of
those orders engendered to their benefit
so I think that there was a um
I think Canadians weren't sure you know
if I'm donating money are my assets
going to be freeze that's something was
that that Canadians were unsure about
and I don't think that government took
much time to really clarify that because
I think the goal was to prevent people
from they wanted to stop people from
donating they wanted to stop people from
contributing to these causes they wanted
to stop people from from protesting even
protesting that didn't interfere in the
way that um that many of the Ottawa
protests did
um so so I I think that those are you
know some things that we want to hear
more um from some of the government
Witnesses about
and regarding the police resources I I
recall
um the acting police chief thing on
numerous occasions
that they did need the emergency
measures act in order
to have
that many was that 1800 police officers
like hundreds of police officers coming
to Ottawa
in order to deal with the the protest so
what do you think of that so
um so I guess I you know I'll I'll need
to hear more from from those Witnesses
when they testify at the public hearings
but I think that
um certainly over the course of you know
the weeks that led up to the invocation
of the ACT
um they they were
you know um they were getting officers
from all over the country they were uh
there are memorandums of understanding
with other police forces so that they
could come
um and and execute their their duties
here in Ottawa
um I don't think that there's anything
that was required from the ACT to make
that happen
next up Mary Kay Walsh global
hi there
um just uh I have many questions but
first of all the
um what you were answering uh first the
hill times about other legislation
I mean the emergencies Act is the
legislation that's there why would they
create legislation to duplicate it
it's like can you just specify more why
that matters and what the distinction is
yeah so I mean the the the federal
government uh declared a state of
emergency using the emergencies act and
then the executive branch passes these
executive orders that are the things
that say you can't gather that financial
institutions have obligations to freeze
assets of people who are designated
individuals those are the things that
um the government could have done by way
of legislation that would have benefited
from parliamentary scrutiny in advance
rather than uh after the fact so but
what is the difference between
Parliament voting to invoke it and the
scrutiny that comes with that versus
having these new laws on an expedited
manner in which they might skip over the
committee process anyways I don't
understand the distinction well the
distinction is that it that that you
have the you have Parliament weighing in
before the measures are in place instead
of after the fact so by the time
Parliament approved the state of
emergency
those orders were already in place they
were already operational
and so and I think also what I was what
I was mentioning before about about some
of the confusion around the scope of the
orders that's also something that might
have been addressed had there been
debate in Parliament in advance
and then I just wanted to get your sense
on
um the commission generally are you
satisfied that the the witnesses that
are listed and the setup of the
commission is actually going to get to
the heart of the question as to whether
the government
met the threshold because we're not
hearing from the provinces we're not
hearing from Doug Ford for example
um you know the accountability for
policing is with the municipality and
the province and the federal government
had to step in because it fell apart at
those levels so are you satisfied that
we will actually get the answers you're
looking for
so I don't know yet um you know I think
we have to see we have to see what
happens during the course of the public
hearings I mean we are hearing from
municipalities that we're affected we
are hearing from Witnesses from from
Ottawa the Ottawa Police Service the
Ottawa Police Services Board members of
council
um
I I think you know I think there's also
questions around
um what will be held back and that's one
of the things that I don't have a good
handle on yet I I know what documents
are have been put forward but I don't
know what documents have been held back
or uh the reasons for that and those are
some of the things that I think will be
explored over the course of the hearing
so I think we will have questions about
whether the government is being
forthcoming enough whether the evidence
is is going to allow the kind of
transparency that we think is required
and I can say that already I mean that
the timeline that the commission is
working under is is
set out in the statute so they are stuck
with it they are stuck with having to
you know put a final report before
parliament in February of 2023 that's a
very short timeline especially given the
fact that the the government waited
almost the full 60 days that they had to
actually name the commissioner so that's
two months that were lost that could
have been used to to start Gathering
evidence and I think that you know they
have a very ambitious schedule the
commission there's a lot of witnesses
they want to hear from there are a lot
of documents to get through there's also
a whole policy phase so I think it's
it's still to be decided and one of the
things that you know that may come out
of this process are recommendations
about amendments to the act around this
process in particular do we need more
time for an inquiry do we need specific
specifics in the legislation that would
address whether the government can hold
things back from the commission or
whether you know everything everything
needs to be provided
David Fraser kidian press
hi just following up on my colleague's
questionnaire regarding transparency how
confident are you in the government's
commitment to transparency are you
concerned at all the the government will
try to Shield evidence
um from being made public by having it
uh presented in camera just to the
commissioner and can you comment uh on
how your confidence level in the
government's ability to be trans
transparent has been impacted if it has
been impacted At All by ccla's um
ongoing judicial challenges
um taking place now as well thanks yeah
so I do have concerns about the the
level of transparency that the federal
government
um you know has has been displaying
through throughout this process when we
are also
um we've also saw judicial review of the
decision to invoke the act and and so
there's been discussions about documents
and about cabinet confidentiality in
that context
um you know and it's not that we don't
recognize that there's a sphere of
activities that the government
rightfully can can protect
um you know but but one of the things
that the emergencies act requires is an
explanation that gets put before
Parliament about why
um you know why the Act was why it was
necessary to declare an emergency
um
for me that document is the government's
answer
um and and if they start to say well
there are other things but we can't
share them or there are other things
that that are we're not at Liberty to
disclose publicly you know I think
that's a problem in terms of of not
being forthright with Parliament
um and not being forthcoming with the
Canadian public
and just as a follow-up outside of what
the government actions that
um the judicial review level has there
been been anything specific to the
commission process that has um
I don't know carried forward your
concerns a little bit more or made you
think those concerns more
um I think it's probably still too
I
just to get access to a documentary
database long before it was made
available to me
um but but I appreciate that the
individuals that are working on the
commission are are also dealing with you
know with a huge challenge in terms of
of all of the material that needs to be
reviewed and and also the back and forth
that they're that they're engaged with
with the parties that have that evidence
so I think it's a huge undertaking but
um like I said we are going into this
with an open mind we want to hear from
from the witnesses
um I think the commission I have every
reason to believe that the the
commission process will be a robust one
um and uh and and a lot will depend on
on how forthcoming the witnesses that
appear are
thank you I believe that's it for the
questions in the room unless you want to
question them in that's that's it so
we'll go to zoom I'll remind every
reporter on the line to use the raise
hand function at this point so I'll hand
you the mic first up uh Alex balingo
Toronto Star
hey thank you so much just kind of
bouncing off uh yeah the these questions
of uh your confidence in the
transparency
um the government uh had said that they
would they would hand over a lot of
cabinet confidences I think that the
quote was all documentary inputs that
went into their decision would be given
to the inquiry
um can you tell us about whether you
feel that what given what you've seen in
the documentary evidence that that is
something that they've actually
fulfilled and one of those those inputs
will be will be public so that the
public can scrutinize all of those
so I think at this stage I probably
can't do that partly because I've just
not managed to get through looking at
everything that the government has has
put forward to the commission and I
think that even what I what I have
access to at this point is probably not
the full scope of what will be put
forward
um
and I think some of it will will also
have to come from questioning Witnesses
about you know we only know what what's
there we don't know what's missing and
so we'll have to ask some of those
questions I think
um
I think also there's a
there are
you know there there are questions in my
mind about you know whether what was
provided to the commission is what is
going to be provided to uh to all the
parties to the commission and to the
public more generally I do know that any
document that is put to a witness or
that is raised during the course of the
public hearings
um should be going up on the
commission's website
um within a day or two of that document
being put forward so I think these
documents will will get you know public
the light of uh that we put before the
public but I don't know yet whether it's
um whether it's efficient
and and just on your your concerns about
the emergency orders and
um you know the open question I guess
about whether they respected people's
rights and freedoms I wonder if you can
just get more specific about which
orders and how uh they may have violated
the people's freedoms sure so there I
mean there were two emergency orders
that were put in place and I'm not going
to remember the the you know one is I
think just sort of called the emergency
regulation and another one is the
economic measures uh regulation
um the the emergency regulation
um restricted
public Gatherings restricted you know
public assemblies it did say that they
were only restricted if they were likely
to give rise to a breach of the peace or
or language similar to that
um again the problem with that kind of
language especially given what was going
on uh in Ottawa is that I think people
who genuinely were interested in
engaging in peaceful acts of protest
um would would have real concerns about
whether they would just be lumped in
with other individuals who might have
been involved in illegal activities so
um so there's a scope sort of question
about that order the the other order
that deals with financial
um
the financial or the economic measures
um basically you know charged financial
institutions all Financial all financial
institutions across the country to
freeze the assets of of anyone
um that
they thought were involved in breaches
of the first order so
um and and again there's there's some
vagueness in these orders and how they
were communicated to the public and I
think even I think this evidence will
come out over the course of the inquiry
um I think even the financial
institutions themselves weren't exactly
sure what they were supposed to be doing
we know that there were names given by
the RCMP to financial institutions
um but in addition to those names the
order itself laid out an underlying
obligation for the financial
institutions to do their due diligence
and and take measures against anyone
they they believed were implicated so
um that's where we got the confusion
from members of the public about you
know are my assets going to be frozen if
I made a small donation or what's the
scope of this
um so I think those are things again
that we'll we'll learn more about over
the course of the um
over the course of the inquiry but when
it comes to how those impacted the
rights of Canadians um you know first of
all there's privacy issues in terms of
uh law enforcement and financial
institutions sharing information there's
no due process with this not even notice
really
um there wasn't a notice requirement so
the financial institutions didn't have
to advise you that your assets had been
frozen
so those are you know significant
um deviations I guess from the norm that
exist in our in our Democratic Society
and those are things that we want to to
question and probe during the course of
the inquiry
thank you next question freezer Needham
from apdn
um yeah thank you I just
I guess that this current uh act exists
is because the more measures act had to
be refined right so that this is the
first test of it um with so many
questions arising as you know that's
kind of why we're here uh whether
um you know it's not even clear that
anyone that was in Ottawa that the the
police here were actively trying to stop
the protest before
um you know sort of the large weekend
that led up to it's being stopped so and
there was
as far as I can remember there's no uh
declaration that by the Ottawa mayor
that needed you know the federal
government step in uh and there was no
um declaration I don't think by the
premier of Ontario that the federal
government needs to step in as well so
is this are you thinking that regardless
of what happens here is that this act is
going to have to be amended because of
uh there's so many questions now around
it
um
I I don't know if I'd say that it that
it would have to be I think the
experience that we've had should inform
um you know potential amendments and and
like I said I mean it this is more on
the procedural level than the
substantive one but just this question
of uh how long does an inquiry have to
look at the questions that that came out
of declaring an emergency and What kind
of transparency measures are required
from the federal government when they do
declare an emergency I think those are
things that could be usefully addressed
by Amendment so
um I would imagine that there will be
recommendations coming out
um of the inquiry that will that will
address possible amendments to the ACT
yeah I guess just to follow up on that I
I are you um for seeing a lot of
questions of uh provincial uh you know
Federal Municipal jurisdiction because
again there's uh you know it didn't
actually happen I'm calling it yeah what
happened in the city of Ottawa
municipality right and it's sort of
their area and then the the
municipalities sort of a creature of the
province and this is a situation where
the you know Parliament just stepped in
uh do you think those those kind of
issues will come up I do I mean I think
they're this is It's Made more
complicated by the fact that we are are
in a you know a federal country and that
um
uh that municipalities are involved and
and even that you know the way that
police over a site and governance is
done varies um across the country from
place to place a little bit so I think
there are
um difficult questions about how to
manage
um something like this where where you
have different jurisdictions with
different
authorities
um engaged
thank you I don't see any more hands on
Zoom so if you don't run out of time
perhaps we have another question in the
room and if other reporters also wants
to answer sure
um Mariko Walsh again with the Globe and
Mail I just wanted to go back to
um your arguments on
why you believe the the government's
invocation of the Act was illegal can
you specify which elements of the
threshold the government has not proven
like where are the question marks in
sort of you know they have to
explain the justification so what what
are the missing pieces for you so I
think one has to do with this question
of a threat to National Security and
what that means um and and this might go
to broader questions about the way that
threats to National Security are defined
under the thesis act which is sort of
the Touchstone that the emergencies act
relies on
um but you know generally we we consider
threats to National Security to be
things that would put people's lives at
risk
um uh you know serious acts of violence
um or um you know genuine attempts to
violently overthrow the government
um those are not thresholds that we
think have been met or at least we
haven't seen the evidence that that
demonstrates that the the other thing I
think is it has to do with the adequacy
of the existing laws
um and and this might be you know a
legal question whether the way that the
ACT is framed talks about they're not
being you know laws that can address it
and and this goes to a question that
someone else posed
um you know does that mean
um that the laws don't exist or that
they're not being applied and enforced
and how do we how do we work through
um those issues so I think there's
there's more information that we need
about the the discussions that happened
particularly between the federal
government and the province of Ontario
about about the powers that the province
had and could have used
um that those are some of the the sort
of threshold questions
okay and just going back to your
question around the documents can be
more specific around
uh what documents you understand that
you will be receiving or you have
received and and where are your question
marks what documents are there question
marks around that you that either the
government has already said it's not
releasing
um or that it's unclear
I I don't think I can answer that at
this stage I have I have access
currently to a large amount of documents
I have not been through them all
um I've also as counsel before the
inquiry given an undertaking that I will
not discuss those documents
um many of those documents will be put
to Witnesses and made public over the
course of the public hearings but I
don't know yet which ones
um and and I don't know I also don't
know
um what what was requested so
um when I'm looking at the the database
of documents
um I don't know what questions were
asked by the commission to get these
documents which which does make it a bit
difficult to assess
um whether it's sort of complete and
answers all the questions that we'd want
keep clarify that will you guys
all Witnesses or only some and if so who
so the parties have the opportunity to
to ask to cross-examine Witnesses
obviously there's a lot of witnesses to
get through there's a lot of parties
involved and the commission has asked
that you know people try to coordinate
and cooperate so that um the um so that
things get get through in the time that
we have
um
I we will not be cross-examining all
Witnesses not by any stretch
um I expect We Will We Will
cross-examine some but a lot will depend
on on how much gets covered because the
the way it will work is that commissions
Council will question the witnesses
first
um and it may be that you know that all
the questions that we have get answered
over the course of that process so we'll
have to we'll have to see
um we'll get a little bit of notice
about what the scope of their questions
will cover a few days in advance of each
witness and then we'll have an
opportunity to decide whether we want to
cross examine David another questions
hey Dave Fraser again with the Canadian
press real quick um just you mentioned
their um interested in learning more
about the communications between the
federal and provincial government were
you surprised or would you have liked to
see Premier Ford on the on the witness
list
um
so I have to I have to take another look
because I know that there are some
witnesses who are not appearing in
person but who who
um there are there are going to be
um sort of statements from those
witnesses that will be introduced I
don't know if
um Premier Ford is one of those
um it may be that that's sufficient
um
I have to say the list of witnesses is
it it's quite long and I and you know
and many of them are names without much
context so it's it's
um I assume there will be witnesses that
we'll be hearing from at the provincial
level
um and we'll have to see whether those
are the witnesses that have kind of the
pertinent information that we need
um as the moderator perhaps I'll just
ask one question one last book
if the commission finds that it is not
supported by evidence that it was not
justified from at the first place then
what what happens well I mean you know
it's it's done right what's done is done
um so but but I think that that's an
important finding I think that's an
important finding for Canadians to to
know I think it helps inform future
governments about when
um when this act can be used
um it might affect how um how people
feel about the government might affect
um you know decisions when it comes to
election time
um so so I think those are important
questions to answer but you know I mean
obviously what happened in February is
is over now so there's there's no sort
of recourse to go back but this is an
important piece of the of the
accountability that's um
that's really mandated by the act itself
thank you merci beaucoup that puts an
end to this press conference
thank you thank you all